SUPREME COURT IF THE TRUMP SIDE
DOESN'T GET THE RULING THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR, JOHN.
>> THANK YOU FOR THAT.
WE'LL BE WATCHING CLOSELY.
>>> IT'S NO SECRET THAT DONALD
TRUMP HAD A STRAINED
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, BUT A
NEW CHAPTER PUBLISHED BY THE CIA
UNDERSCORES JUST HOW TROUBLED
THAT RELATIONSHIP WAS, EVEN
BEFORE TRUMP OFFICIALLY TOOK
OFFICE.
FORMER INTELLIGENCE OFFICER
WRITES, IT IS THE MOST DIFFICULT
IN ITS HISTORICAL EXPERIENCE
WITH BRIEFING NEW PRESIDENTS.
THE ONLY AND IMPERFECT ANALOG
WAS THE NIXON TRANSITION.
TRUMP WAS PRONE TO FLY OFF ON
TANGENTS.
THERE MIGHT BE 8 OR 9 MINUTES OF
REAL INTELLIGENCE IN A
CONVERSATION.
THE IRRECONCILABLE DIFFERENCE
WAS TRUMP WAS FACT-FREE.
EVIDENCE DOESN'T CUT IT WITH
HIM.
WE ARE NOW JOINED BY THE
PUBLISHER AND CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER OF LAW FAIR, ALSO A
FORMER INTELLIGENCE CIA OFFICER
HIMSELF WHERE HE BRIEFED GEORGE
W. BUSH FOR PART OF THAT
ADMINISTRATION.
HE'S ALSO THE AUTHOR OF THE
"PRESIDENT'S BOOK OF SECRETS: A
HISTORY OF THE PRESIDENT'S DAILY
BRIEF."
THIS IS CALLED CHAPTER 9,
"DONALD J. TRUMP, A UNIQUE
CHALLENGE."
EXPLAIN WHY HE WAS THE MOST
DIFFICULT SINCE NIXON, DAVID.
>> UNIQUE ACTUALLY IS A VERY
GOOD SUMMARY.
JOHN DID A GOOD JOB WITH THAT
TITLE BECAUSE IT CONVEYS SO
MUCH.
IT WASN'T THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS
UN-BRIEFABLE.
HE DID HAVE INTELLIGENCE
BRIEFINGS DURING THE TRANSITION,
AND HE DID KEEP THEM THROUGH
MUCH OF HIS PRESIDENCY, BUT
THOSE BRIEFINGS WERE DECIDEDLY
DIFFERENT THAN WITH ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT.
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP DID NOT
WANT TO SIT THERE AND LISTEN TO
THE OBJECTIVE FACTS AS JUDGED BY
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
HE WANTED TO TALK.
HE WANTED TO INTERRUPT.
HE WANTED TO ASK QUESTIONS.
AND NOT REALLY FOCUS ON WHAT THE
EVIDENCE WAS AS MUCH AS WHAT HE
THOUGHT THE EVIDENCE WAS.
THAT LED TO A VERY DIFFICULT
RELATIONSHIP FOR AN INTELLIGENCE
ENTERPRISE THAT HAS BEEN BUILT
UP OVER DECADES SOLELY TO GET
OBJECTIVE INFORMATION BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT.
>> LOOK, YOU'VE WRITTEN ABOUT
THIS, EVERY PRESIDENT IS
DIFFERENT IN THEIR ENGAGEMENT
STYLE, BUT THERE'S THIS
ABSORBING OF THE INFORMATION.
WHAT WE CAN SEE FROM THIS
CHAPTER IS TRUMP WAS NOT DOING
THAT NEARLY AS MUCH AS PREVIOUS
PRESIDENTS.
THE PERSON WHO WAS WAS VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE.
HE WAS KIND OF RECEIVING THESE
BRIEFINGS MORE LIKE A PRESIDENT
THAN EVEN PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS,
IT SEEMS.
>> RIGHT ON.
THERE'S A COUPLE OF PEOPLE,
OTHER THAN PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
THE ADMINISTRATION, WHO GET SOME
ATTENTION IN THIS NEW MATERIAL.
ONE OF THEM IS VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE, WHO WE DIDN'T HAVE MUCH
OF A WINDOW ON FROM THE
REPORTING DURING THE
ADMINISTRATION REGARDING HOW HE
TOOK INTELLIGENCE.
THERE WAS AN ASSUMPTION THAT HE
WAS GETTING THE PRESIDENT'S
DAILY BRIEF AND TAKING THE
INFORMATION SERIOUSLY.
FRANKLY, THE VICE PRESIDENT
DOESN'T HAVE AS MUCH TO DO AS
THE PRESIDENT.
AND PERHAPS HE'D HAVE TO STEP
INTO THE PRESIDENT'S SHOES,
PERHAPS MORE LIKELY WITH THIS
PRESIDENT THAN ANY OTHER, GIVEN
THE TWO IMPEACHMENTS.
PENCE SHOULD HAVE BEEN DOING
THIS, AND THE MATERIAL SHOWS HE
WAS.
HE WAS TAKING BRIEFINGS QUITE
REGULARLY AND ENGAGING HEAVILY
WITH HIS INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
INTERLOCKETERS.
THERE ALSO IS A FOCUS ON MICHAEL
FLYNN IN THIS DOCUMENT, WHICH IS
QUITE INTERESTING, REGARDING
WHAT HE HAS BEEN UP TO LATELY.
MICHAEL FLYNN, UNTIL PRESIDENT
ELECT TRUMP, WAS FULLY BRIEFED
ON ALL CIA COVERT ACTIONS THAT
WERE AT THE BEHEST OF THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT, BARACK OBAMA
AT THE TIME, THAT DONALD TRUMP
WOULD BE INHERITING AS HIS
COVERT ACTIONS ON INAUGURATION
DAY.
MICHAEL FLYNN GOT THAT BRIEF
FROM THE CIA ALONG WITH VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE BACK ON DECEMBER
7th OF 2020.
TRUMP DIDN'T.
IT WASN'T UNTIL SEVERAL WEEKS
INTO HIS ADMINISTRATION THAT
TRUMP GOT BRIEFED ON ALL OF THE
COVERT ACTIONS THAT HE WAS NOW
RESPONSIBLE FOR.
IT WAS QUITE A REVELATION.
>> YOU MEAN WHEN FLYNN WAS
BRIEFED IN 2016?
IS THAT WHAT YOU MEANT, TO BE
CLEAR?
>> YES, 2016, NOT 2020.
>> I WANTED TO BE --
>> 2020, MICHAEL FLYNN WAS IN A
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCE.
>> THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
HEADLINE.
SO HE ACTUALLY DIDN'T GET --
TRUMP DIDN'T GET A BRIEFING IN
THE LAST MONTH OF THE
PRESIDENCY.
>> THAT'S HOW IT APPEARS.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT DODGEY, THE
WAY IT IS WRITTEN.
IT IS ALMOST AS IF IT DIDN'T
WANT TO BE SAID THAT BLUNTLY.
BUT BEFORE DONALD TRUMP LEFT FOR
MAR-A-LAGO FOR THE HOLIDAYS,
WHICH WAS SOMEWHERE AROUND
DECEMBER 23rd, 2020, THAT HE HAD
HIS LAST BRIEFING WITH HIS
REGULAR PDB BRIEFER, AND SAID,
"I'LL SEE YOU LATER."
SHE WASN'T PLANNING ON GOING
DOWN TO MAR-A-LAGO AND BRIEFING
HIM DURING THE HOLIDAYS.
LATER MEANT WHEN HE CAME BACK IN
EARLY JANUARY.
BUT THE BOOK SAYS THAT HE CAME
BACK, AND THEY WERE SCHEDULED TO
HAVE A BRIEFING ON JANUARY 6th,
BUT THEY DIDN'T HAVE ONE AND
DIDN'T HAVE ONE UNTIL THE END OF
TRUMP'S TERM.
WHICH ADDS UP TO ALMOST A MONTH
OF NO INTELLIGENCE GETTING TO
THE PRESIDENT THROUGH THE
REGULAR BRIEFING PROCESS.
THIS MATERIAL ALSO SHOWS THAT
EVEN THOUGH THE PDB WOULD BE
DELIVERED, HE MAY HAVE LITERALLY
TOUCHED THE BOOK, AS HIS FIRST
BRIEFER SAID, BUT WE DIDN'T
ACTUALLY READ ANYTHING.
SO IT IS A SHOCKING REVELATION
THERE, TOO, THAT THE COMMANDER
IN CHIEF OF THE UNITED STATES
DIDN'T GET ANY MATERIAL FROM THE
PDB FOR VIRTUALLY A MONTH AT THE
END OF HIS PRESIDENCY, IN A VERY
CHAOTIC TIME.
>> YEAH.
IT IS STAGGERING.
YOU KNOW, YOU MENTIONED, AS WE
SEE TRUMP'S STYLE HERE,
INTERRUPTING BRIEFINGS, WHAT IS
THE MATTER WITH THAT?
WHAT IS THE MATTER WITH
INTERRUPTING A BRIEFER OR
CHALLENGING A BRIEFER?
>> THIS MAY BE SURPRISING, BUT
THERE IS NOTHING AT ALL WRONG
WITH THAT.
IN FACT, WHEN I WAS A BRIEFER,
MOST OFTEN FOR BOB MUELLER AND
JOHN ASHCROFT, BUT A FEW TIMES
INTO THE WHITE HOUSE, I ACTUALLY
WANTED THE CUSTOMERS, AS WE
CALLED THEM, TO INTERRUPT.
THEN I WOULD KNOW WHAT WASN'T
WORKING FOR THEM IN THE WAY I
WAS PRESENTING IT, AND I WOULD
KNOW WHAT WAS OF INTEREST TO
THEM THAT I NEEDED TO ADDRESS IN
THE LIMITED TIME WE HAD
TOGETHER.
SO THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
INTERRUPTIONS.
THERE IS SOMETHING WRONG IF THE
INTERRUPTIONS MEAN THAT THE
FUNDAMENTAL, BOTTOM LINE
ASSESSMENTS CANNOT BE
COMMUNICATED.
IF THE MESSAGES THE ENTIRE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY HAS BEEN
GEARING UP TO TRY TO GET TO THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF CAN'T GET
THROUGH BECAUSE THERE IS TOO
MUCH CHAOS IN THE ROOM.
IT LOOKS, FROM THIS NEW
MATERIAL, LIKE THAT'S CLOSER TO
WHERE WE WERE AT OFTEN IN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THAT CLAPPER SAID, I THINK HE
TEED UP 8 OR 9 MINUTES IN A
ONE-HOUR BRIEFING THAT IS
FOCUSED ON INTELLIGENCE.
THAT'S NOT HORRIBLE.
YOU CAN COMMUNICATE A LOT OF
INTELLIGENCE, BOTTOM LINES, IN 8
OR 9 MINUTES.
THAT WAS A HOPEFUL NOTE IN THE
NEW MATERIAL.
OTHER DAYS, IT SURE SOUNDS LIKE
NO MAIN MESSAGES WERE GETTING
THROUGH.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH SOMEONE
WHO INTERRUPTS SO OFTEN TO HEAR
HIMSELF TALK, THAT THE
INTELLIGENCE BRIEFER CAN'T DO
HER JOB GET THE INFORMATION OUT.
>> I LOVE HOW YOU SAY, THAT'S
HOPEFUL.
YOU ARE AN OPTIMIS